let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 caller from 9 1 9 hello who's
there what's on your mind today oh yeah
this is David from Durham North Carolina
great David I just hey David glad I get
to talk to you I found your your show
online and boy I love I love everytime
you going on there thank you I just
walked in the door and I saw I read a
headline that Trump wants to cancel NBC
and all those other is is that is it
just getting more insane or is that a
real it's not a real article yeah it's a
real article sadly and so we've been
basically seeing a three pronged
approach a three pronged attack on media
from Donald Trump number one has been
during the campaign talking about
opening up libel lawsuits just making it
easier to sue media outlets and that's
really dangerous you know we don't want
to restrict media's ability to do
critical and investigative reporting and
we already have laws against libel so
then number two is along net neutrality
lines net neutrality the attempts to
rollback net neutrality to from a
technological standpoint just make it
more difficult for media to operate and
to make it make it worse for independent
media which would be separate from NBC
and then lastly has been Donald Trump's
assertions and these have happened on
social media on Twitter this idea that
he decides what's real news and what's
fake news that he decides who should be
shut down and who shouldn't be shut down
from the point of view of sort of
government regulation which is funny
because supposedly Trump is part of the
party of the free markets and of letting
the free market dictate what's around
and what isn't around and so it's it's
been a dangerous attack and yes
unfortunately David that's a real
article that Trump is talking about the
possibility of or wanting to see certain
media outlets shut down and we should
all be very scared no matter your
political orientation yeah I agree with
you a hundred percent I'm gonna stop
reading the news for a couple days I'm
depressed yeah but it's nice talking to
you David keep up the good work alright
thank you
likewise always great to hear from other
callers named David Kent
go wrong with that